rushon Gordon Ramsay to me is so special
because of its uniqueness
it runs on passion adrenaline and more
importantly creativity every time you
step through those doors you feel
special every time you light up that
stove in the kitchen it feels unique and
every dish that flies off that hot plate
it's magical
having spent the last thirty years
mastering my craft the experience that
gathered and the knowledge I have goes
into every dish that gets created but
more importantly run by a team that are
equally talented hungry ambitious and
absolutely at the top of their game
[Music]
the man running the kitchen behind
Gordon Ramsay is mapa Bay one of the
most talented one of the most driven and
one of most passionate chefs in Britain
today
having that young tenacious ambitious
creativity on those plates today helps
to keep ration Gordon Ramsay at the top
of his game
[Music]
it's fronted by the most amazing maitre
d jean-claude who eats drinks sleeps
restaurant Gordon Ramsay
there's no maitre d anywhere in the
world with that level of insight memory
and passion jean-claude service in my
mind is the best in the world
the head sommelier James Lloyd
James is palate as a top sommelier is as
finessed as a young chef his
encyclopedia mind of the blend of the
grape and the understanding of the dish
that was matched brilliant without wine
comes down to years and years of
experience
[Music]
raishin Gordon Ramsay over the last 20
years has helped to reinstate the
importance of British cuisine it's
highlighted some of the best produce
grown locally I've always said from day
one the better the product the littler
needs known to it
you never ever forget for decades about
the flavor that's the memory that you
can never buy
for me the secret of the next 20 years
is to stay on top of the game never ever
take your foot off the gas and remember
you're only as good as your last plate
Russian Gordon Ramsay to me is more than
just the Russians it's my life
[Music]